to show multiple layers and if one has a
transparency so we can see the other
ones underneath okay so let's take a
look here so what you're saying here is
chill image so wait a minute the generic
geo image so just until we understand
what we're doing this generic chill
image of let's do this here okay jus
image of Spain the generic chill image
it's just that yeah my default satellite
I see but this is but if we were to give
specifically relief map here then we
will get just the relief map exactly so
now the question for example we have
this other layer called state map labels
only which is transparent except for the
labels that's a really weird name what
does it have to do with the street map
it is the labels that the state map has
but a street map would have would have
exactly like a woodchuck would have if I
mean it's if we had streets them I mean
that's kind of weird
we also have state map no labels which
is the other parts the complementary
part okay I consider that kind of odd
because the fact is that the labels it
has nothing to do with streets it
happens to you know often come from
OpenStreetMap as it happens but it has
nothing directly to do with streets it's
merely basic labeling right yes if we go
to very high some levels we would have
the names from the streets exactly but I
mean why don't we just say labeling or
labels as a layer type has anything to
do with street maps and it's just labels
relief map and labels because you know
some backgrounds don't have labels some
backgrounds do have labels yes
with it but Labor's implies to me it's
just the labels nothing else well it is
if I do this look that's the whole point
that's that's what we're saying here is
that if we say that's that's the point
these are the disembodied labels see
right I feel like this is more than the
label what is this
I feel like the dots are not the labels
fair point fair point well maybe that
needs a different maybe do we have the
the labels only without the dots or do
we only have the dots on the labels
right now we only have these both things
together well what is the right term for
this
I mean labeling maybe label map I'm not
sure which of these things what what
does what we call satellite imagery what
do we so we have satellite and satellite
with labels in to some extent its
locations yeah I don't think locations
makes it I think that's like um this is
really weird
Street Mountain no label I'm sorry sweet
that labels only that's a really weird
then I think we should call it a
labeling about it in layers right I mean
at the point of this is building maps
with maybe three four five different
layers oh no no I understand but I would
recommend calling this labeling
but it can be labeling off you know Kemp
Krauts are labeling off you know I think
I mean many different things
give me railroads can be roads can be
city labels can be rivers can be you
know like the radar image it's not about
the boy something that works but but
with all those things yeah we've got it
we've got a certain I think if we just
say labels only or just labels that will
make sense in this list I think the
words street map there is very
inappropriate I mean I would go with
seed labels or you know like no but
that's a different thing on owed yes if
we can break those apart and say what
level of labels they are we absolutely
should do that but there's also just the
generic labels up whatever zoom level
you're at see what I'm saying
Hosea is that is that correct that
there's one box of all labels at
whatever zoom level you're at can I
share an example no I just wanted Jose's
answer to that what do you mean by one
box I mean that whether this is okay so
let's do an example here so if i say
here gio range arrow you know twenty
miles okay
I mean it's not you still have country
so that's taking the center of the Conn
I'm starting to see here is all kinds of
random street labels right I think we
have Francisco here I think these are
called shields in general yes these are
so in the label layer we have we add all
the things with words and they include
also the shields with our also labels
with some square use it in general for
roads for example fine that's because in
this layer but maybe that's something we
will want to split in different layers I
don't know yes okay fair enough
I know it is sending did you want to
share another so I just pull up your
community now just pull that page and
scroll to the about halfway down the
page there's a good example of a
different layer which is just hiking
trails in the UK upload it yet right
there so that's it so that's hiking maps
that that's also a layer you know so you
cannot just I think you cannot just call
that one Street Map layer just I had a
cycle I understand I understand but
we've got right now a thing that we are
providing which is the aggregate of all
labeling layers right that's that's what
this named feature is here now we
probably this list should probably get a
lot longer and should have different
kinds of label layers in the making
sense yes though we are working in the
direction of separating the labels to
graphics part not not a raster part as
theses the text labels as label
as I close six strings yes right but
okay fine but the question of whether
geo image does that and how geo image
does it and whether it rasterizes them
as a separate question that's in
Geographics obviously it will try and do
that in geo image it would probably
rasterize the you know whatever is done
with with raw factor you know labeling
make sense yes but properly rather than
having a language in the Dior styling
argument we should have the Geo labels
option having that language for for
specification of which type of levels
you want fair enough okay but so then
here we could simply have a layer well I
don't really know how that will work but
I can imagine different layers here I
can also imagine that mapping into
right-hand sides for geo labels right
what we could do is what you're saying
having a labels layer here which is
going to extract whatever was produced
by the Geo level option and rasterize it
that's fine okay but let's take a look
at what you're doing here
yes so the basic idea is simply having a
list of layers which are overlaid while
one after another there matters I think
that's fine oh no do you object to that
sorry I was going up something else what
was the question
this design your background of a
sequence of layers in order bottom to
top I know but what does it have to do
with backgrounds I mean because now you
have yes one background layer right
which is like that has to be non
transparent has to be opaque and then
there's things that are transparent on
the top so those are not really
background things anymore they're all
background this is Geographics so it's
got graphics primitives
that's the way I'd the way I see it is
that there is one background image right
that's like a satellite image or it's
like you know and anything that's
completely opaque non transparent and
then there's layers that lay on top of
that like labels or trails or railroads
or any sort of other some theme
there's the point - oh those are not
backgrounds
well let's see we could have in the
first argument a sequence of polygons
each one containing a G of styling with
a different layer we could do that as
well but the simplest thing in general
is having layers that cover the whole
mat and align in I mean do background it
seems like the simplest thing to do and
anyway all these layers are the
background of any input you put in the
first argument of your graphics
that's what maybe we should have some
examples of how you could put any points
your markers etc and all this is the
back room of this right which is exactly
correct yeah what is this here so these
this is a more complicated case in which
we have we are mixing here the relief
map is a raster layer then the country
borders is a vector layer with with all
the borders of the country and it takes
parameters specifying the colors of the
oceans land so so this is quite useful
when you want to have we already crossed
the bridge of having this kind of syntax
or not yes yes it's the other it's
documented and you know it'd be vitally
for example uses it a lot with his black
colors but with India styling in your
stunning yeah so so your background is a
dear stunning it's just that well when
it is just a string we can avoid there
where is that where is this phone
documented with ocean arrow white and so
on yes it will be in Berlin scope okay
but is it documented up here where where
it needs to be probably here it's not it
should be yes yes but I say I am sure
they have examples in scope yeah I
understand what they're example to
that's not enough
if coastal lines and country borders
should have examples of of different
colors yeah that one for example yeah
okay so that's completely unmentioned
above which it yes
it should be yes okay um yeah I wonder
if we should extend these country
borders to to any political border in
general a way to specify the level for
example that will be nice
well I think I would leave country
borders as a name thing administered the
division borders and then maybe one of
the parameters is something about the
level or we could just say you know we
should be able to say state borders or
first level of minister to Division
borders or something I don't know what
the right name is and I don't know what
some but I agree that that's a highly
desirable to be able to get that so I'm
a little bit confused why are these
things here like country borders not
available in geo image or are they are
they available as a background option
well the ones that are Victoria are not
available because your image is going to
produce and we could just erase them we
should we should we should have a
compatible set available here okay but
the other thing is based on our actual
data reduction we should allow a whole
bunch of other different layers right
like roads only like you know I don't
know parks cities whatever else does
that make sense
Francisco does that make sense to you
yes well that will mean adding these
layers to to your server but they all
will use the same database so so they
are not really going to use more
database on the more tiles in the
recomputed cachet but I think that's
fine because they are not that large
really many empty space are not that
large fine seems like a good thing to do
so we need to get names for those things
so this last last example is also
imitating what Arnie was doing which is
Colleen layers from different Joe
servers yes and so this is a way of
showing
that by using the your server option of
just Eileen not the one of Geographics
we can do that as well by the way let me
ask this question is in these geoserver
things do you have to know all the
detail here or could you just say you
know could you just give that part is
the rest of it so that's why we're
talking that's all we're talking about
if you go to the community post in the
background
did you can name all of those things
like scroll up a little bit
you see where it says geo service like
we can do something like that I don't
know if it has to be exactly like that
that's yeah they're like like
symbolically naming you know those URLs
not sure if we can do that in the in a
legal term I mean what I mean is that
not all these services allow you to
expose that's a separate issue which we
can guess we look at the I mean you know
this is very similar to service connect
where sometimes you would have to get
authenticated and you have to get you
know credentials for that service right
yes so we are working in the direction
of the different protocols of
communication with a year server and
some of them more modern ones allow you
to download the file that contains all
the information about the server what we
have right now forces you to specify all
the details of the year server and if
they have some non-standard tile sizes
or whatever you will have to specify
that in advance right so this geo
service wrapper you might you might say
service connect to one of these things
you might give all your credentials and
so on and then you can call geo service
does that make sense yes for example
with digital globe we are not doing that
exactly but something equivalent which
also needs authentication since Allah or
will need eventually or an API key
somewhere so I'm just have an API key
like you can
be online and then it just provided by
me so then you would say Joe service
authentication arrow whatever and that's
fine too okay so those are some examples
of that's that's great
naming the file servers and doing the
translation from like that's really nice
yeah long URL so this is this concept of
you know so the main concept that you're
introducing here is different concept
than the first one we're talking about
is a Geo service concept right but now
where are the tiles I don't quite
understand the no I don't understand
this at all they're two different things
here one is the Geo server where are you
getting this stuff from is it and the
other is what are you getting I don't
quite understand what the I would have
thought well right now that's basically
it within the Geo styling that you're
specifying for that particular styling
but but I understand the typical thing
is that you go to one of these places
and it is the defaults return from that
place that you will as the styling yes
so that's dummy yeah it's some some
third-party services have multiple
layers so they're slightly different
URLs for different layers okay but maybe
we have to name those as different geo
services if we doing this protocol
connection that will be inside this
protocol connection which layer to
connect for example in a TMS servicing I
don't know WM is but so what you're
suggesting here instead of geo styling I
mean this doesn't seem like the right
thing here this is I mean essentially
what this is is your background our
I don't know whether we want to call it
Geo service well at your background
option is always a dear styling and we
and I think it's useful if after
downloading the image from the Year
server we can still process it with
farther options of the Geo styling okay
well I don't think you want to then say
geoserver want to be able to say geo
styling of geo service that's a wide
year service well I think it's it's kind
of wrong okay but the points is that you
don't want three levels of indirection
here of having to come up with a name
which it might not have any of that you
know the fundamental thing is the
railway map or whatever it is mhm right
is whatever is being returned by that
external service is the payload you want
to return here that is I want my geo
background to be or my geo whatever it
is or my thing in a polygon or whatever
I'm doing I want that to be you know the
thing that is rendered in the map right
should be your layer or something like
that
possibly but then I mean external geo
layer would be a you know I don't think
this is quite the right name I'm
confused there are two different things
we're trying to deal with here okay so
that's the beginning of this discussion
we're saying that we want an additional
set of of internally named layers that
we have pre pre curated yes we agree
meet yes okay so
so we've got our own curated layers and
then part two and within our own curated
layers we have this mechanism of saying
geo styling of this named layer here
right relief map is just an abbreviation
of just styling relief map yeah I get it
okay so now the issue is what do we do
with an external geoserver which
potentially has a default layer in it I
suppose what we could do is just delight
this and say here I mean just allow an
illusion I mean that might be the best
thing to do is just say this could be
out to my take or something yeah just do
that right okay and now the third layer
of this is something where we're saying
that's the second argument or the third
argument of your styling which sorry I
misplaced it it should be the second
argument
okay so then geoserver would come lost
yes yes I misplaced this is very weird
because this would have a directive I
mean this is not an ambiguous
disambiguate able exactly that's why I
think automatic would be would be nice
yes so yes I misplaced that so so then
here this would end up becoming geo
service of our server side or whatever
it is right because that's the symbolic
wrapper potentially with authentication
arrow whatever it is right so what we
are doing right now is that it's a bit
like projections we take instead of on a
string we take a list in which the first
argument is a string and say did I glow
or something with a list of parameters
so just service here could be a list
simply and then this would be also
understood
yeah I think it might be nice to have an
actual notion of a geo service which
could have a you know a summary blob
that represents it and things like this
yeah I don't know I don't know how how
prominent is how many of these are there
I mean are there hundreds of these that
we could be tying in to thank you
there are many yes well I think this is
more us what we should do and I think
that we can have a list of geo services
which again will need you know
documentation pages just like we have
lists of you know service connections
and so on right okay what else do we
have to figure out it this looks great I
mean it looks like a good thing there's
anything else to figure out here no I
don't think so
okay seems good and I support the idea
of having a geo service all these
concepts or of different protocols I
think so okay terrific okay so I think
Francisco ombred perhaps can leave
unless they're interested in this
discussion which is very interesting
the main question here is the fact that
we are using quantity with temperature
unit in two different ways and we have
had some complaints from users and this
is an example if you divide one over
quantity of one degrees Celsius we get
coverage well I think we get currently
what is the right thing for quantity but
users expect it to be able to transform
to kelvins automatically and so so
users respect the second one not the
first one and so the point is that with
this current language we have no way of
specifying the difference unless we use
a different name for the unit and the
suggestion is to follow the difference
between data object and quantity and
introduce a separate object called
temperature okay let's let's ask couple
questions here okay okay first of all
what other things are there in the world
like temperature are they entropy things
that are like temperature or is
temperature a unique Michael let's go
you know physics philosophy here I mean
temperature obviously has a very
specific you know it why are we in this
bind with temperature but what's special
about temperature okay I think that
there are very few peak use that we use
with respect to reference quantities
that we measure linearly and temperature
is trust by far the most common one the
only other one that is even reasonably
coram common is gradual is why is
pressure measured with respect to a
reference because we live in ice what
you're saying so it's a pressure so when
we say well I mean we have an absolute
pressure of you know 2 milli Torr or
something which is relative to the
vacuum are you saying the over not sure
know to be TV measure of this respect to
our Co in the a pleasure
typically to international pressure but
it's not true I mean when you say it's
you know you know 101 3 milli bars or
something that's relative to the vacuum
that's not relative to yes but sometimes
people refer to the difference with
respect to some standard pressure okay
that's a different thing I mean are we
supporting that if you put pressure in
your tire you measure against air
pressure you do it
your tire but not for meteorological
pressure for example let's go if I
didn't say all but
many professionals or not pleasures and
templates are the only ones that
typically are measured against
references okay and pressure only
sometimes measured against another day
right a template author like in the
moment you use absolute one you're not
against the reference right what about
all the things with concentration with
with international units and all those
weird things aren't those done with
respect to a reference somehow with
respect to references I don't think so I
think they are just basically
conversions to to certain absolute ones
they're not business process you know
take 50 au vitamin a is not against 20 a
you base yeah okay all right what about
um okay so there are other things
what about decimals and things yeah
that's a different story
those are exponential units algorithmic
units oh yeah but why are those yeah we
are to treat those separately and those
will need also special treatment but
it's a very different discussion okay
all right okay so here there is an
implementation if you evaluate the
section code then we can play with
examples it's really we have a
temperature object maybe just go to this
is this is the code you can go directly
to the example section so again it's
it's a bit like data object it could
have even its own type setting this is
just a simple implementation and the
thing with temperature is that they have
scales which are like calendars for date
object yeah I understand
so use your concept is there is a
temperature I mean I don't understand in
a sense we could say the same thing
there is a length
and it is merely a scale that says
whether it's measured in meters or feet
the thing with with temperatures is that
because people didn't know that there
was an absolute zero they started
measuring temperature from random places
and and now that we know that there is
an absolute temperature we have this
mixture of situations in which sometimes
temperature is used finally
and sometimes it's used linearly and
again to me this is exactly like we have
discovered now that the universe had a
beginning so we could measure dates from
the beginning of the user of the
universe it's just that because we don't
know it with enough precision and it
would be a huge number we would not do
it but yeah many of the comments we get
from users with respect to temperatures
because they are trying to use the
standard physics formulas with 1 over T
or T to the 4 etc and and and they
expect our quantities of 1 Celsius to
work there by automatically convert into
Kelvin and it doesn't work cannot work
what happens when when they want this as
a difference of temperature that's the
well if you subtract to temperature
objects here they will give you a
quantity it's exactly like that object
I say tition temperature into absolute
you know outside temperature is a
temperature expression and a difference
between temperatures is a quantity
because the problem we've run into with
quantity outside of simply use of
temperatures which we sort of broke into
we have degrees Fahrenheit and degrees
Fahrenheit difference but as soon as you
end up with a compound quantity or a
compound unit where you say it's 3
degrees Fahrenheit per meter suddenly
that degrees Fahrenheit unit should be
an absolute temperature but in any
reasonable usage it's actually referring
to a difference in temperature which is
where some of the quirky behavior comes
in because the same unit used in a
quantity in combination with another
unit suddenly takes on a different
meeting yeah but this combination unit
thing
okay I'm a little confused here okay so
the main issue you're claiming is that
is that this is a linear scale on which
the numerical value depends on where you
put the zero right I mean in the case of
a link yeah there's a very well-defined
zero the thing has no length so to speak
exactly so the question is so the
problem is and as you you're giving the
analogy of time where there is no
natural zero of time until you know the
universe has a beginning exactly so and
the problem the issue with temperature
is that once we know what temperature is
and we know that you know at some
temperature kind of the atoms stop and
somewhere there's no kinetic energy or
whatever well there is but it's not
there's zero point energy but we're not
going to talk about that the the what
else is like that is isn't entropy like
that too so it has a I mean it well
entropy one might think
yeah people thought and tributes like
that but it's not because ultimately
there is a there is only one degree of
freedom there and or there's only one
possible State and so the entropy is
zero and that's what ties the thing to a
zero right but people thought that
entropy was relative I mean it's the
other way round from the temperatures
here analogy shots potential soldier may
have a zero yes okay so let's think
about that for a second okay so electric
potential has the same issue of
potential difference versus if you say
inverse volts yeah why aren't you
getting the same as you with inverse
volts well I think because people don't
there are no formulas in which you have
to divide with respect to our natural
zero
I think the issue is that we have
dedicated units for the absolute and
relative forms
whereas with potentials there's just the
same units there is no absolute
potential unit well I'm confused by that
so this is the statement you know with
electric potential there is no absolute
zero there's no natural absolute zero of
potential is that a true statement or is
that you know I don't know it's the
potential at infinity somewhere no I
think that's a true statement right that
that's the starting point of PD gauge
invariance yeah fair point okay so that
so the claim for potential is because of
gauge invariance basically there is no
there is no well-defined zero and the
analogy of that with temperature it
isn't there some whole curve caret
what's the call careth for the air a
theory of temperature or something that
has some whole analogy with
transformations like that I don't
remember how it works but in any case
there is a well-defined there is no
gauge invariance so to speak with
respect to temperature because there is
an absolute zero
what about okay to ask what about the
gravitational potential and that's a can
of worms but the gauge invariants there
is of something quite different if I'm
not mistaken you've got enough relative
a song is called somebody should be able
to answer that what's is there an
absolute value of gravitational
potential there is a convenient warning
some problems but there is no absolute
but just for my education the gauge
invariants with respect to whatever it
is the diffeomorphism group or whatever
it is I mean is that is that equivalent
to saying that there isn't is that
equivalent to the same thing as the QED
scalar one or is it not
which is related but it I wasn't saying
I wouldn't go as far as saying it's
equivalent fair enough but okay but so
you believe that for fundamental physics
reasons there is no absolute zero of
gravitational potential correct yeah
okay so what are the other things so
that's a difference is only by the way I
don't even know we have units what are
the units of gravitational potential
well there is something called Galileo's
gun for the potential oh yeah that's
right and it's used in engine yeah right
okay fair enough okay but so I'm just
I'm sorry I'm gone poking this issue a
little bit more trying to understand why
temperature is special right so to need
something which is quite interesting is
that one of these scales which is this
is an example a deal it's called a
denial scale happens to go both
backwards so it has the the freezing
point of water to 100 and the boiling
point of water at zero so with this
construction we can implement this scale
while for example with quantity it's
impossible to have a quantity in which
you add positive numbers and give you
something smaller and if if I'm not
mistaking I mean this unit we don't even
have it in a quantity framework because
the quantity framework even in alpha
cannot support it and very interestingly
the original Celsius scale happened to
go in this way as well
it had the zero at boiling point and 100
at freezing point and it was reversed
the same year that Celsius died and by
somebody else has no idea he was
involved okay but in a sense this this
shows that this object
has they the full flexibility of
implementing ivenna I scaled that the
goes in the opposite direction are you
saying I mean for other cases like
obviously right ascension aka or or
latitude/longitude those things I mean
they have a conventional way of going
and we have no great interest in
supporting them going backwards we don't
but for example longitude as astronomers
use longitude in the opposite direction
because it's more convenient for them to
look at the sky and so and now this is
something that has been changing the in
the last 50 years or so because it
confused everybody else so they are
switching back to our standard
convention but for many but declination
are you talking about declination right
ascension type stuff are you talking
about something different I'm saying
that for convenience at looking at the
sky astronomers used longitude on the
earth in the opposite direction
increasing towards years they were great
okay but you're saying that convention
is being reversed yes it's not used
there are some books of sister numbers
starting saying oh why are we switching
barque given that it was so convenient
but yes it's been switched okay but look
in general with these weird and wacky
you know unit things like temperature
units running backwards and so on I just
don't think we have any reason to
support those in other words there are
plenty of things in the history of you
know in the history of a bunch of these
areas I mean we could support I don't
know some I mean I don't think we need
to support historical bad notational
ideas I'm not saying we do I'm just
saying that this shows that this is the
right framework to support the general
case and if we wanted to implement that
it would be very easy to do without your
projection we could have a job
projection which has strongly to
traverse it so I'm trying to say that
this is the right framework to work with
okay let's look back at what you're
proposing here so you're proposing
it just seems so arbitrary to pick out
temperature as the only you know
physical quantity for which one has to
do this I mean you're pointing out the
date is another one right these are
super fundamental ones for people and I
think the fact that it also has a nice
typesetting could also help people that
know nothing about absolute temperatures
things like that to not be confused
right okay so let me ask you another
random one so let's take the SI base
units right so let's just go through
them okay so so you know temperature is
one
what about illumination isn't that
another one it's always temperature is
not a unit I mean the the base what are
they called that the five or six things
what's that the dimension see stay clear
for naming them oh great
okay well what but there's a list of
them right length yes mass length time
yeah let cetera right one of those is
candy loss or something right is
illumination yeah is that have a similar
does that have a well-defined 0 this is
evils because this is respected human
area that's a subjective unit what human
area it's not that it's not objective
think okay but but so are you saying I
mean what I'm trying to poke at is
whether there are other units okay so
let's say we do something like this for
temperature are there going to be other
really random units like you know chili
pepper scales or something let's start
coming out of the woodwork needing to
have the same thing done to them because
the question is whether we want some
kind of you know quantity scale object
there is a general way of doing this or
whether we do it specifically for
temperature I think with respect to real
human usage temperature is probably
special measure everything does respect
to something
yes I understand well I mean it would be
pretty silly to measure length with
respect to something to start you know a
thing with zero length and to say well
no that's actually length minus twelve
but think of elevation where do you
start measuring narration yeah that's a
good example but say the continent lift
it would be silly to give it an absolute
scare you give it with respect to the
coordinate distance say the year 2000
do not give 12 digits you mean 2
millimeters per year yes exactly
is it as a position difference so to
speak yeah but so explain to me why if I
were to take the continental drift and I
were to divide by the continental drift
for example I won't get a stupid answer
in the same way that I would get no like
if you would say what's the distance
between the coordinates not a drift
mm-hmm it's fine because the concept
goes away but you're saying the just
internal continents then what you would
you would typically only speak about the
change of the distance of between two
continents you would never speak about
the physical absolute distance yeah okay
so what's the analogy for temperature
about 20 DT which is the temperature
difference
exactly but yet you know the formula for
you know 1/2 KT is an absolute
temperature the conversion to energy is
an absolute involves an absolute
temperature right so what should you say
it doesn't do it for length might they
be cases where you do it for legs like
elevation I think that's the best place
for like oh like you you measure this
tiny difference in the change of the
arms you don't measure the length of the
arms
okay okay let's go through what this
temperature object is supposed to have
and I unfortunately have to go to
another meeting in a minute and I this
is not quite as horrifying as I thought
it would be I'm still trying to
understand okay so you're proposing this
temperature thing which represents an
absolute temperature well it represents
a temperature that is not neither
absolute nor anything it's just a
free-floating temperature in the sense
that a date is a free-floating date that
doesn't isn't with respect to zero ad
isn't with respect to the origin of the
Jewish calendar isn't with respect to
the beginning of the universe type thing
exactly right
right and that's why it has a scale not
a unit exactly in the same way that data
objects have calendars not time janet's
well it's interesting and you think it
is not a generalizable concept not to
other units this this is for example
this is calendars for date objects and
like projections for geo objects I think
but it's nothing that people typically
need will do so we can't find equivalent
concepts in what is this why is there a
picture of a thermometer here but not
here that I was discussing with Michel
that the kelvins are typically used by
physicists and physicists would not like
the thermometer and I agree that that
differs but but is it your way of
indicating that one of them is an
absolute thing and one of them is not no
no no no they represent exactly the same
thing it is dead we thought physicists
would not like that's if I might say so
in the in the category of kind of weird
but I mean I I personally am NOT a big
fan I mean the decoration that we're
using for date objects of that little
calendar thing I'm not a huge fan of I
think the smaller and simpler that gets
the better I mean it's just losing up a
bunch of space and it's really pretty
obvious you
when when you know a date has a
particular I don't know I don't know
what that really adds um so I mean is it
straightforward if we if we agree to do
this temperature thing is the
implementation fairly straightforward is
it obvious what to do or other weird
cases where okay so what happens if you
try and unit convert it the temperature
thing yes so here it's working with the
Geo position model which is wrapping
another do position around will do the
conversion so we have three models they
transform although the convert model and
they see a position molar say with a
wrapper so zero position right I don't
think we I mean the battle might work
but I think unit convert better work
yeah but the problem is what happens if
you say unit convert and somebody will
just say oh I want it in Fahrenheit but
there's a whole fahrenheit scale story
here and so on but I don't think a unit
convert should work here it's more like
temperature converter it's like in the
same way that we have what is it convert
or calendar convert or currency convert
right so you this is not changing units
this is changing the scale by the way
let me add a horrifying one I mean in
the in the world of currency converts
there's all of the conversion between
the different precise time measures of
you know you what is a UTC versus you
know all the things that depend on the
glitches and the motion of the earth
which like like currency conversion are
not predictable
that is so I'm saying we have not
addressed that yet for time right so
Nick and I are planning to have a option
time system option in the same way that
we have a calendar and other options for
timezone we need another one which is a
time system but how do you do the
conversion I mean the conversion depends
on how do you do that conversion them
the historical data we need to know
historic
okay but if it was for the future what
would you do we cannot
it's absolutely deceive an error message
yeah we cannot extrapolate just like if
you ask for currency conversion for
future tough luck exactly but people do
worry about exact amount of times in the
past sure yeah right
unit conversions of temperatures right
now for example if you convert five
degrees Celsius it will use the
conversion with the whole formula not
only they let's say the factor between
for example when you go to Fahrenheit
that's equivalent to what you want to do
with this temperature conversion isn't
it exactly because I think a quantity of
five degrees is a temperature difference
so it should convert this by multiplying
by a linear force if we start changing
quantity to read this other way of
conversion you know what is that what is
the transition plan if we do that
because we have a bunch of places
obviously where people have 20 degrees
centigrade is treated as a quantity yes
yes so my view of this is that this is
fixing an ambiguity now yes we are going
to change the cases in which the input
was ambiguous so some people will have
to change something but it's going to
fix bugs that have been reported because
people expected the other interpretation
well the other question is what does
control equals 20 see actually do I
think most people would expect that to
give your new temperature your new
temperature scale type thing right 20
see they don't think is a temperature
difference usually and this is what it
should do in the future is to give this
temperature object rather than giving
the thing which can be interpreted but
now if somebody writes I mean it's so
confusing if somebody says something
plus control equals you know 20 see then
that would be a temperature difference
in that case
if we could do it you know if we could
look at the context for the control
equals then we could tell that if I say
if what we say if somebody is typing
something like well let's imagine that
they typed I mean this is a very nasty
case 20 C okay okay absolute you know
thing on a temperature scale plus five C
okay I mean I have no idea what this
does right now okay
that's pretty funky it does that because
you're using the same unit we have some
forgiveness in here again because of the
ambiguity well I mean that's not
obviously wrong that is not you know
that seems like it's actually right
right it's implicitly understanding that
one of those needs to be a temperature
difference unit but if you say plus five
F well let me do this one that's a
horrifying thing yeah for comparison if
you do that on the Alpha website you get
something fairly different because it
handles those inputs differently it
interprets them in a way that still have
some trouble parsing out but because we
can put the assumptions as something
more meaningful in unison right but
these these operations are now ambiguous
so by using it's a few lines before
temperatures and quantities no matter in
which scales or you look at it right
it's all meaningful
but this first one you would do what
would happen if you try to add to
temperature objects I mean if you add to
dates you presumably get a stupid answer
right if I say today plus tomorrow it
refuses to do anything with quantity
will sorry with temperatures there is
always the way out of saying oh do you
want the formula in Kelvin and convert
to Kelvin and this is probably what most
people will want because we have
formulas like 1 over T e to the 4 I
think that these are all formulas in
which what we are saying is no matter in
which we scale do one convert to as
Kelvin and continue you have some heat
expansion and you heat it a little bit
more and you add you don't want to go to
orders
but when you add a bit more then you
have a quantity you have to careful with
temperature difference so that's my
whole point that you will be able to
specific to clearly specify whether you
want one or the other right sandir on a
live stream is reminding us about our
kelvins difference unit right what is
the relationship what is the story with
the difference we've already got this
notion of a difference unit Committees
of bi p.m. and is T especially in the US
version document n is DSP 811 say that
the handling of temperature and
temperature difference units in cave in
is not ideal and might be very careful
to differentiate between temperatures
and temperature differences but the
official use of a second unit
temperature difference is not sanctioned
but it's also not not not for well so
what do we do with this that's yet a
third
by the way how recent are these various
pronouncements xx okay okay listen I
gotta go to a different meeting um we
need to continue this sigh this is
complicated I mean look the end results
will probably be that we'll have this
temperature object probably I'm just you
know it just concerns me that that we're
you know it it concerns me to
distinguish this in that way because it
doesn't I'm not really totally convinced
that it's so different but maybe maybe
it's true
I mean the elevation case is an
interesting one right that's another
case where there's a very complicated
notion of zero and in fact you know it
well right I mean it's you know above
ground level above you know mean sea
level all these kinds of things right
yeah a secret cetera right is that we
can handle all of that through the
current the opposition Jo framework have
we done that I mean in an alpha for
example we do for you know for aviation
type stuff we have whatever it is AGL is
one common one right above ground level
and and then you know yeah we have
things like flight level three five and
stuff like this right yeah but we're not
doing any conversions or things we are
use showing the data right now for these
things it so I understand I mean in that
case like convert flight level three
five to you know elevation above ground
level so the right thing to do there is
to add the language of vertical datums
so right now your position knows all
about horizontal datums but not
vertically that's something I'm working
on derivation data has so those things
which I'm describing those are talked
about as vertical datums yes and and you
can you could refer to various notions
of sea level
in various places so same for different
countries etc that time dependent
what dependent on the tides Excel yeah
okay okay
to be continued this will be interesting
but I gotta go and do something else
right now thanks guys thanks to folks on
the livestream good some interesting
good comments I'm a year later